ryan gosling gushes over being a dad  et spoke with the 35 year old actor at  the premiere of his new movie la-la-land  on Monday at the Toronto International  Film Festival where he opened up about  being a father Ryan and his longtime  girlfriend Ava Mendes have two little  ones together  Esmeralda who just turned two and Amata  who's just five months Gosling also  revealed to ET that one of the scenes  from his new flick was based off of one  of the worst auditions of his career was  actually seen in the film which is based  on an audition that I had where it was a  very emotional scene that I had to do  and halfway through the lady took a call  and just kept talking while I was  supposed to finish my line so when I  told Damien he had put it in the script  so it's in the movie lala land hits  theaters December 2nd